we begin with the conflict in Ukraine
Russia says Ukrainian artillery has hit
the city of Donetsk in the East the
Russian appointed mayor says Kiev used
cluster Munitions Al Jazeera cannot
verify that claim yet a university
building caught on fire because of the
shelling he received supplies of cluster
Munitions from the United States last
month
Ali Hashem was at the scene and sent
this report
this is the University of economic CI in
dunyatz it was hit apparently with one
missile on Saturday night just after 10
pm there were several explosions ahead
in this city many thought it was the
defenses as usual but later on we
understood that it was a missile attack
now the building and it's a vast
building actually that extends to the
right and left is on flame and many
firefighters many cars here trying to
battle the Flames as you can see inside
the building the the Flames are eating
the ceiling it's a it's a very old
building 100 years old building and as
we understood till the moment there are
no casualties reported however there are
fears that this building might collapse
from dunya's Kali Hashem Al Jazeera
let's bring in our correspondent Steph
Vossen she's joining us live from the
Ukrainian capital and Ukraine is saying
Russia has launched a significant number
of strikes overnight step
yes absolutely most of the night Ukraine
has been on the Russian Air Attack the
Armed Forces here say 70 air assault
weapons were used missiles drones and
they managed to intercept most of them
but still at least 10 missiles have hit
their targets what we know is that last
night president zelensky tweeted about a
blood transfusion Center being hit in
kupiansk but this morning the district
Chief in hakif in that area has called
it a non-residential building so there's
no more information about exactly what
that building is in the kupians region
we know that two two people have been
killed and four have been injured but
also residential areas have been hit
their farms and Villages and also an
Airfield in the west of the country has
been the targeted we don't know any
details of about that as well all right
step and we have seen a real increase in
attacks from both slides over the last
few weeks and at the same time we have
the Saudi peace conference that's taking
place in in Jeddah it's the second day
of the conference what was achieved on
day one
yeah I have to say that of course Peace
feels far away at the moment with all
these increased attacks happening but 40
diplomats from 40 countries are meeting
in Jeddah right now discussing zelensky
zelenski's peace plan and there hasn't
been any official statement coming from
Jeddah but what we're hearing is that
the especially the participation of
China is highly appraised and this is
very significant because this is the
first time China is participating in a
similar kind of peace peace meeting that
was also held earlier in June in
Copenhagen then China didn't appear but
the fact that they are attending this
time is very significant and basically
what this is is that zelenski Ukraine is
reaching out to The Wider World Beyond
only his Western allies to show that
this war is not only affecting Ukraine
it's not only affecting Europe but it's
affecting the whole world so what they
want is that they that there's going to
be a real piece Summit so what the
European Source has said that so far
they have agreed that Ukraine's
territorial Integrity should be defended
and the U.N Charter and that they will
have working groups on this peace plan
10 point peace plan about food Security
nuclear safety and all the other issues
that zielinski wants to put forward and
this European Source says that there
might be a summit later this year with
leaders included all right step thank
you very much for that step bus and with
the latest live in Kiev